[MUSIC PLAYING]
CARTER MORGAN: Welcome
to another episode
of "VM End-to-End," a show
where we have a VM skeptic
and a VM enthusiast get
together and hash out
all things VM related.
Brian, thanks again for coming
in and spitting knowledge
at me.
BRIAN DORSEY: I'm so
excited about this one.
Disks, disks, disks.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah, you would--
I don't understand this.
I've been trying to figure this
out for three episodes now.
What is it about disks that
is so exciting for you?
BRIAN DORSEY: I
think part of it,
for me, is that I think
almost all useful systems have
to store their information
somewhere, right?
Your system has a memory,
and you care about the data.
Most of the time, that's
on a disk somewhere,
or ends up on a disk in the end.
And so I think, for me,
it's where systems get real.
And--
CARTER MORGAN: OK.
BRIAN DORSEY:
--that's the big deal.
CARTER MORGAN: I could see that.
It's a fundamental
unit of computing.
And so that's what's exciting.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
And on that unit,
we think of them
as physical hard
disks or maybe an SSD.
But let me turn
this back on you.
In the cloud, in Compute Engine,
what do you think a disk is?
CARTER MORGAN: OK.
All right.
Going back to a slice of a
data-center model, to me,
a disk would be
a bunch of pieces
from real physical
machines spread out
over a data warehouse
or a data center,
pulled together, and
presented to me, the user,
as one logical disk that I
can work with and operate on.
BRIAN DORSEY: Exactly.
Spot-on.
CARTER MORGAN: Yes.
BRIAN DORSEY: That
is exactly it.
And in fact, some of that-- so
it's a network-attached disk,
right?
And it speaks of a protocol.
And even physical disks, these
days, speak of packet protocol.
So SATA is serial ATA.
And they talk about the blocks.
So here's a block of data, or
give me that block of data.
And ours speak of similar
protocol, but over the network,
to a group of disks.
CARTER MORGAN: So
I guess, what is
it that's exciting about
that, and especially
the network-attached part,
because what I care about
is performance.
I care about backups
and scalability.
I care about reliability more
so than a fundamental unit
of computing.
Where do these disks sit
in relation to those?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
OK.
This is a meaty question.
So I think, actually, let's talk
about each of these in a row.
So performance, to start.
I think performance is tricky.
What does it mean to be fast?
And I think there's actually
two different parts of that,
for disks.
One is throughput.
In a bulk, how much
data can you copy over
a certain amount of time?
And the other is latency.
So how quickly can you
get a response back
to a specific question?
CARTER MORGAN: Right.
It feels like a
physical disk is going
to be faster than that because
I don't have to communicate over
a network.
That seems like
common sense to me.
BRIAN DORSEY: And I agree
it seems like common sense.
And it's true for one
and not for the other.
And it's weird why that is.
So as physical disks are
getting faster over time--
sorry, as they're getting
larger and faster--
but they're getting
larger faster
than they're getting faster.
So there's more and more
capacity on the disk.
And the window to
read and write that
is not getting as big as fast.
So if you're talking
over the network
to hundreds or
thousands of disks,
you can actually get
more overall throughput.
So the throughput
side is an area
where we are actually faster
than a single physical disk.
But sometimes-- there is
a little extra step there.
So if you need the absolute
lowest latency read,
you might need something faster.
So we have a product,
local SSD, to do that.
CARTER MORGAN: And
that's basically
just literally attaching a very
fast hard drive to a machine.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah, it's a--
CARTER MORGAN: OK.
BRIAN DORSEY: --physical
SSD on the host
that we are running your VM on.
CARTER MORGAN: OK.
So that seems, to me, like--
I come from video
game programming.
So is it something I
would use for maybe
an inventory-management system?
Something like, I recall
items in inventory often.
Is that a good fit for this?
BRIAN DORSEY: It would seem like
it, but I think, in this case,
probably not.
So the local SSDs are actually
intended for temporary storage
because they are mapped
to this physical host.
And we want our VMs to be
long-lived and able to move
around.
So there are cases
where we can't
have the data live as long as
you might like on a local SSD.
So they're best fit for
things like caches or data
that can be regenerated by
processing or transcoding
workloads or things like that.
CARTER MORGAN:
Intermediate calculations
in math or vectors or whatnot.
OK.
BRIAN DORSEY: Absolutely.
CARTER MORGAN: All right.
That makes a lot of sense, then.
So then what does
Compute Engine offer
when it comes to different
types of physical disks
or different types of
PDs, persistent disks?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
I think there are
multiple different types,
and I'm probably not going
to go into all the details.
But the basic
breakdown is an area
that I think you
didn't hit here that I
think does matter to everybody.
And that's cost.
CARTER MORGAN: Oh,
that's a big one.
Yeah.
BRIAN DORSEY: So it
basically boils down
to a price-to-performance ratio.
So when you have a
workload that is really
performance-sensitive, there
are versions of persistent disks
that can hit that.
And they tend to be a
little more expensive.
And if you've got a
workload that is mostly
about storing information, and
you don't access it that often,
there are less expensive
modes of PD to do that.
CARTER MORGAN: And
that makes sense to me.
If I was a
small-business owner, I
might not need the
speed and scale
that, say, a company
like the size of Google
would operate at.
BRIAN DORSEY: And--
CARTER MORGAN: So then--
BRIAN DORSEY: Sorry, I
just cut you off there.
CARTER MORGAN: --to
not get into-- oh--
BRIAN DORSEY: But--
CARTER MORGAN: Mm-hmm.
BRIAN DORSEY: --to that point,
I think lots of workloads need
both as--
or, systems need both.
You've got a long-term storage
and a high-speed portion
as well.
CARTER MORGAN: OK.
That's actually a
really good point.
So then, OK, talking
about systems--
and like you said, in
systems in the while
might need two types of disk.
What about backing up
these kind of systems
that are in production?
Do these virtual-network
disks actually
help with reliability
or backing up data?
BRIAN DORSEY: A lot.
Absolutely.
So like you said, it's this
logical collection of blocks,
right?
So in many ways, I
think it's like having
most of a SAN, a
storage area network.
So you get most of the features
you would want from that.
And by that, I mean you can
take a snapshot of a disk, which
makes a point-in-time copy
without slowing the disk down.
So you can make backups of
live systems any time you want.
And the other thing
you can do is,
you can take an existing
disk, and you can just
make it larger, even while
it's connected to a machine.
I feel like everybody
has run out of disk space
at some point.
CARTER MORGAN: I have a laptop,
and it's run out of space.
And there's nothing I
can really do about it
other than plugging in
an extra hard drive.
So that's a feature that
makes a lot of sense to me.
You said something earlier about
snapshots and whatnot, though.
And I'm curious, what's
exciting about that?
How does that become usable
in a production system?
BRIAN DORSEY: So there's the
straight-up backup use case,
which I think is important.
But then one of the big ways we
scale computers these days is--
there's vertical, and
there's horizontal, right?
So vertical might be like
making the disk bigger,
like we talked about.
And then horizontal is, add more
computers to the mix doing it.
And so if you have
a computer that's
set up the way you
want it to work,
you can take a snapshot of that.
And then you can
make multiple images
of that that are running
on multiple machines
and have them work as
a group to do the work.
CARTER MORGAN: OK.
That is actually really
cool, because you're
going to get reliability
and consistency there.
You're not going to
get human errors.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
CARTER MORGAN: I am
a huge fan of that.
Is there anything else there
that you want to touch on?
Because, like you said, you're
going to get backups from this.
You're going to be able to scale
vertically and horizontally
from this.
I feel like those are some
really big benefits to disks
and why they're
useful, and even more
useful than having a physical
non-cloud-native disk.
So what do we need to follow
up with in the future?
We said cost.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
CARTER MORGAN: I missed cost,
and that's really important.
So let's definitely
have an episode on cost.
What else am I missing?
BRIAN DORSEY: I think a whole
episode there makes sense.
And then, I think,
with the scaling stuff,
you get more moving
parts, right?
So if you go horizontal,
you'll have more computers.
You'll have more disks.
You start-- need to think
about networking patterns.
And so it's useful to
have some automation
to set that up and configure
it in a consistent way.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah,
and I'm actually
excited about that because
I'm a big fan of automating
as much as I can.
I make mistakes.
I don't want to risk it.
Brian, thanks again for
just taking the time.
I've got to admit,
slowly, you're
winning me over, because--
BRIAN DORSEY: Love it.
CARTER MORGAN: --there seems
to be a lot of benefits.
Thank you.
That's all for us this episode.
If you're watching this at
home, let me know anything
that you think we missed
talking about or anything
that you thought was very cool.
I'm getting won over right now.
Are you with me or no?
Let us know in the
comments below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]